in boss baby yes they showed you're
promoting your your the German bad guy
yes that's very true now and you and I
know that you have Oh feel free to I've
made across it
you may yes always good to ask first
yeah you I would never man those are
very tight jeans is it painful for you
to cross your leg a little bit I feel
that some light head yeah are you
crushing your your various mandibles yes
it's the chestnuts are roasting this is
nice that you're wearing cellophane oh
yes this is a deflated two disco ball
what you look fantastic
thank you so much well do you Conan and
also Andy well I was bringing up but you
play the bad guy you you have to love
because one of my favorite bad guys of
all time was the German bad guy in in
die hard Hans Gruber I knew you he is he
is and I'm obsessed with him I'm always
thinking up that's him at the end
following but I'm just curious
tell me did you yeah you a Hans Gruber
fan as was Hans Gruber how would I think
about him in Germany in die hard I it is
my favorite of the action films in the
woods oh that is a nice hippie time I'd
like it a question than the SIPPs that's
enough well wait a minute what you don't
have to announce it you can just have
you can just take a little sip you don't
take a little sip
take a little sip with me okay yeah well
you didn't need to do any of that you
could have just had a sip sorry I was
dehydration okay oh yes
die hard die hard yes this is your
favorite of the movies my favorite of
all if the action films and all of the
Flint's in the general you know sorry
overboard and all of the others wipeout
and whoo-hoo-hoo yes just no phone call
to who it was well portugal's it was so
anyway what did you like so much about
in die hard what do they call die hard
yes you're a mini what's it's German
name well we can't say die hard
it doesn't sounds correct so we have
translated it but we don't always know
the perfect of the translating yes so
die hardest earplugs um which means to
die die very slowly yeah so we do this
it with many of the American films yes
and so my most favorites yes one with is
it Sigourney Weaver Sigourney Weaver
uh-huh yeah it's called a gorillas in
the mist you have this one so exciting
look we're the Monkees I see them riding
yeah okay and it was translated to
Google us in Coke a less amenable which
means what which means gorillas in the
fog it sounds like a weather prediction
we got some gorillas in the father rode
in the park hello yeah okay so do you
ever get insulted that yeah many movies
yeah I mean I imagine you do yeah yeah
welcome to this bandwagon
yeah no no you look like a baked potato
here oh let me sour cream myself with
your chives Andy feel free okay do you
ever get it let me finish the sentence
yes I do you ever get insulted that
Germans are always the bad guys in
movies no do you know why why I mean
have you have you Wikipedia Germany
history
we're not Finland you know you've got
some nice cell phones and lots of
natural resources yeah yeah so so you
think that maybe it's okay yeah actually
I'm a little I must say offender
depositors yeah because when I'm
watching a bad guy ferns and cycads a
German man yeah he doesn't speak with a
German accent always he is British I've
noticed that I've watched a lot of
movies where a Tom Cruise did a movie
where they play that like there's a plot
against Hitler and everyone in it was
British and all the German guys had
British accents what happened what did I
miss this was the support of history
with it or like Oh teas and crumpets
teas and crumpets and then now know we
have tremon accents yeah what do I
Valkyrie tell me why I don't know right
you're asking the wrong guy it's a very
good why yn do you tell me why there's
something weird about a bunch of German
speaking English and then having German
accent is you know yeah there you go out
of like why they could have any acts in
the accent yeah yeah could be anyone
awesome hi Don hello shrimp on the
barbie yeah yeah yeah okay I have a
question for you please I have an answer
for you okay if Germans play bad guys in
all the other films who plays bad guys
in Germany determines very safer where
who should play back we should play the
bass
you